good morning believe nation today's
message is life is much larger than
failure and success over to you Sri Sri
Ravi Shankar life is much larger than
failure and success life is much larger
than birth than death
we are much beyond them all got it if
you have this strength if you can
understand this knowledge then you will
walk like a king
nobody can shake you so what you think I
think when you hit the point in your
career or in your business we are not
afraid of failure where you realize that
your collective experiences are
something you can take with you to the
next thing when you realize that having
a bad day is not the end of everything
or even if you fail you don't lose
everything I think once you hit that
place of being comfortable with who you
are it opens up a sense of freedom
across business across your personal
life it lets you know that that failure
is not something that you really have to
be afraid of yeah like it I think the
odd I would say the thing that drives me
is more impact it's not it's nice to
have goals it's nice to have my billion
entrepreneur goal like having shorter
term goals I don't want to stretch for
but all of that is part of being an
impact on people's lives helping people
get better help helping people believe
in their dreams I use that approach in
my business career but also family and
personal you know my friends my wife my
son my parents I want to have an impact
on their lives help them do what they
want to do and that at the end of the
day is what I mean sending late night
emails challenging entrepreneurs to I
like to send this guy late-night email
yes we given arguments by email
sometimes but it's because I care right
and because I want I want people to be
the best version of themselves why I do
this channel right I want you guys to be
the best version of yourself and not
just strive for some monetary goal or or
some you know I want to be published in
this magazine or get my book out not
just specifically but I want you guys to
live the best version of your life and
for you to go out and have an impact on
the world as well so the question of the
day today is what's your greatest fear I
like that one
leave in the comments below we're gonna
join in the discussion thank you so much
for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and we'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
of espresso